one of the most exciting reveal from
Marvel's phase for slate at San Diego
comic-con Hall each panel was the reveal
of Doctor Strange to Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we knew that
we were going to be getting a Doctor
Strange too but we had no idea that we
beginning it in phase four and we had no
idea that it would contain the
multiverse in it the first Doctor
Strange talked very little about the
multiverse although they did mention it
but now it seems like Doctor Strange 2
is going to die fully into what the
multiverse actually is we also learned
that Wanda Maximoff is going to be
playing a big role in Doctor Strange 2
as well which is super exciting and now
we have learned about the villain of
Doctor Strange too many people have
speculated that it will be nightmare
especially since Scott Derrickson the
director of the first Doctor Strange
film has tasted in the past but with the
first Doctor Strange film set enough
more dough to become the villain we were
unsure of what we'd get in Doctor
Strange - well now according to a report
we have some confirmation so I'll break
it all down in this video quick reminder
if you'd like a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment with
your favorite superhero or villain I'll
be picking a new winner at 500,000
subscribers
according to a report from we got this
covered calm a source to them told them
that nightmare will in fact be the
villain of Doctor Strange - this comes
from the same source that told them that
Black Adam will be inches am-3 which has
been proved to be true and that
shang-chi will feature the real Mandarin
which of course has been proved to be
true as well as it is called shang-chi
and The Legend of the ten rings
according to this report from we've got
discovered calm Doctor Strange will
become aware of the threat when
nightmare starts hunting down people in
their dreams causing the hero to face
off against him however it seems like
nightmare is going to have the upper
hand at first as their source told them
that nightmare is going to make both
Doctor Strange and the Scarlet Witch see
some very weird and crazy things and
apparently this is where the horror
elements of the movie are going to come
in if you are unaware it has been
confirmed that Doctor Strange to Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness is
going to be the MC use first horror type
movie that is still of course going to
be pg-13 but they are going to make it
very different with the horror aspect so
nightmare is going to be the villain of
Doctor Strange to Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness
however according to this same report
Mordo
and Dormammu are not yet done apparently
dr. strange three is going to show more
dose descent into darkness then Mordo
and Dormammu will team up to go against
Doctor Strange in Doctor Strange three
so for Doctor Strange to Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness nightmare
is going to be the villain he will go up
against Doctor Strange and the Scarlet
Witch and make them see some weird and
horror type things much like the Scarlet
Witch did to the Avengers in Avengers
age of Ultron I got eyes on the prize
[Music]
Morda will most likely make some sort of
an appearance in Doctor Strange - but
will really become the villain and
Doctor Strange 3 when he teams up with
Dormammu to go against Doctor Strange
remember Doctor Strange no longer has
the time stone so it would make sense
that Dormammu would return so let me
know what you think about this news of
nightmare being the main villain of
Doctor Strange - Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and vendor Mamu
and Mordo being the main villains in
Doctor Strange 3 be sure to let me know
your thoughts on these villains in the
comments down below and also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and I'm also still giving
away Marvel Legends items as well when I
hit the 500,000 subscriber mark be sure
to follow me on Twitter and Instagram
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof